So we've just had a chance to learn a bit about debugging,
which is made up of testing and then trying to localize or isolate the fault
and then fixing it.
I actually had a chance to work at a lovely company in Santa Barbara,
Green Hills Software, where my job was to do just that
for just the sort of interpreter that you're writing.
Every day I'd come in and there would be a stack of input programs on my desk,
and our interpreter--or our compiler--was currently computing
the wrong answers for them.
And I would do this sort of hypothesis testing that we've been considering here.
I'd say, oh; what if the bug is in the top half of the program?
Then I can comment out the bottom half, and I should still see the bug.
Oh, that didn't work.
Maybe I'll hypothesize now that the bug is in the bottom half of the program.
I'll comment out the top half and we'll still see the bug.
And I could refine my way down--maybe it's in the top fourth,
maybe it's in the top eighth, until eventually I had a very small input
that still showed the bug.
And then it was easy for me to localize the fault and fix it.
The process was relatively lockstep, so lockstep in fact that a few years ago
a researcher, Andreas Zeller, published a technique for automating it.
His approach, called Delta Debugging, makes it systematic--
does this systematic hypothesis testing by dividing a program input
in half and half again until it finds the smallest input that still reproduces the bug.
In fact, looking back on it now, the job that I had is almost completely automated.
When you run into defects or bugs in your code, and you probably will--
I certainly do all the time--I want you to apply that same level of formal reasoning.
Think about where the bug might be.
Make a test case that probes or falsifies that hypothesis.
Localize the defect.
And then move in to fix it.